The DARPA Grand Challenge
is a competition
for autonomous
vehicles sponsored
by the Department of Defense.
The vehicles must be
able to navigate a course
and avoid unexpected obstacles
all without human interaction.
The 2007 competition will
take place in an urban setting
with vehicles having
to obey driving laws
and deal with traffic.
For the first time,
MIT in collaboration
with Olin College and
the Draper Laboratory
is entering the grand challenge.
MIT's entry uses a combination
of lasers, cameras, and radar
to perceive its surroundings
and detect obstacles.
Its software then uses the
data from those sensors
to determine the
safest way to proceed.
When the vehicle encounters
an obstacle in the roadway,
the car stops, backs up, and
examines its surroundings,
and then plots a new course
to safely maneuver around
the obstacle.